[Musique]
thierry mariani bonjour bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation dans la
matinale de rtl france alors on le
disait rentrée des classes pour les
élèves de maternelle et primaire avec
finalement une citation encore toujours
fragile 1 et les parents mis à
contribution pour que les enfants qui
peuvent bien n'aille pas à la cantine
regardez ce qu'a déclaré jean michel
blanquer le ministre de l'éducation
nationale s'est hier j'ai un objectif
fondamental qui est l'intérêt des
enfants et l'intérêt des enfants c'est
d'être à l'école d'apprendre d'être
ensemble et puis les enjeux de santé
la cantine en fait partie on aurait pu
faire prendre les mesures de fermer les
cantines
c'est vrai que c'est le maillon faible
j'ai toujours dit mais en même temps
c'est très important pour les enfants
d'avoir un repas équilibré tous les
jours si on peut éviter que les enfants
aillent à la cantine c'est mieux mais
les cantines doivent rester ouvertes
alors cette rentrée scolaire avec la
question des cantines est ce qu'elle
aurait dû elle aurait pu être décalée
selon vous comme l'a souhaité d'ailleurs
à votre présidente marine le pen
ou alors effectivement l'éducation de
l'enfant doit primer je pense surtout
qu'elle aurait pu être mieux préparée en
réalité qu'est ce qu'on a fait de ces
semaines de vacances rien si vous
regardez on apprend que il y aura quatre
cent mille tests salivaires à
disposition pour détecter chez les
élèves et les enseignants
quatre cent mille pour les millions
d'élèves c'est ridicule
est ce qu'on a mis en place les
autotests les autotests ans aperçoit
quand nous les avait annoncé il ya que
quelques pharmacies qui les ont est ce
qu'on a trouvé des solutions pour les
professeurs remplaçants quand ceux ci
seront positifs on a appris que le
concours ou que la campagne de
recrutement du ministère de l'éducation
a été un échec
donc le vrai problème c'est que ces
trois semaines le break j'allais dire de
pause il fallait les faire mais il
fallait les mettre en place pour pouvoir
mieux détecter et mieux protéger les
élèves
si vous permettez je prends parce que
deux exemples en autriche depuis le mois
2 février les tests salivaires sont en
place justement pour les pour les élèves
un allemagne les élèves se teste deux
fois par semaine
en france rien une fois de plus on est
en retard alors l'actualité de ces
derniers enfin cette image aussi dans le
parc des buttes chaumont à paris qui a
beaucoup circulé sur les réseaux sociaux
on a vu des jeunes faire la fête en
musique sans distanciation social vous
le voyez à l'instant à l'écran sans
masque qu'est ce que ça vous ce qu'est
ce que ça vous évoque ce type de fête
sauvage et ses images précisément goûter
c'est consternant relâche pas que
l'écrasante majorité des français
respecte les chaînes les gestes barrière
le port du masque etc
je comprends que par moments on va y
faire la fête mais à mon avis ce tir est
ce pour ça irresponsable consternant et
je pense que tous ceux qui à
s'astreignent à respecter les
précautions doivent partager la même
chose le même sentiment quand je vois
ces images je les ai déjà eu dans ma
région en provence alpes côte d'azur
souvenez-vous de ce carnaval il ya deux
ou trois semaines à marseille
et bien voilà c'est irresponsable est ce
que vous l'avez vous le comprenez ce
sera le bol d'une partie des français
aujourd'hui et bien sûr que je le
comprends bien sûr que je comprends la
détresse des étudiants qui sont privées
de leurs cours et qui sont coincés chez
eux
bon maintenant le confinement s'est
enfin assouplies même si on est en
retard là aussi par rapport à la
totalité des pays européens
mais de là à faire ça c'est consternant
voilà on peut à la limite au moins avoir
un masque au moins essayer de prendre
ses distances voilà donc j'ai envie de
vous dire je peux à la limite le
comprendre mais ça ne l'excusé pas alors
l'actualité ce matin c'est aussi cette
nouvelle loi sur l'irresponsabilité
pénale elle a été annoncée hier par le
gouvernement alors que plusieurs
milliers de personnes étaient
rassemblées pour contester l'absence de
procès après ce terrible meurtre de
sarah halimi halimi state il ya quatre
ans emmanuel macron avait lui même
demandé au gouvernement de se pencher
sur le sujet c'était la semaine dernière
regardez décidé de prendre des
stupéfiants et devenir alors comme fou
ne devrait pas à mes yeux supprimer
votre responsabilité pénale
là aussi pas de fausse impunity alors
tiré mariani vous vous saluer l'annoncé
de cette nouvelle loi sur
l'irresponsabilité pénale
après cette affaire halimi écoutez
d'abord j'ai coûté 1 ce matin l'avocat
de la soeur de madame halimi ya quand
même un problème de justice
voilà le juge d'instruction n'a pas
ordonné de reconstitution il y avait
plusieurs experts en art qu on n'a
retenu que la vie de celui qui
expliquait que la personne était
irresponsable
il est évident que assassiner quelqu'un
en disant mon dieu c'était sous
l'emprise de la drogue c'est pas ma
faute c'est quand même hallucinant que
cette personne ne soit pas jugée et
n'aille pas immédiatement en prison
après ce gouvernement en 48 heures nous
a annoncé de nouvelles lois une nouvelle
loi pour répondre à ce déni de justice
avec ce meurtre de sarah halimi une
nouvelle loi
suite à l'assassinât d'un policier voilà
le problème c'est pas d'avoir de
nouvelles lois tous les jours le
problème c'est d'avoir d'abord détester
lois qui sont appliquées
et puis une justice qui par moment
j'allais dire rendre la justice et et ne
donne pas toujours des conditions
atténue des conditions me réduite des
excuses aux coupables quand on assassine
quelqu'un
quelle que soit sa religion sous
l'emprise de la drogue et pardonnez moi
vous à pas forcés à prendre de la drogue
si un si vous tuez quelqu'un sous
l'emprise de l'alcool vous faire prendre
de l'alcool bien ces personnes qui sont
ils responsables doivent payer pour
leurs crimes alors la justice montré du
doigt après l affaire halimi vous le
rappeliez mais aussi après le verdict
ensuite à l'attaqué
des policiers s'étaient à vitry
châtillon le conseil supérieur de la
manif de la magistrature a réagi
hier regarder le conseil supérieur de la
magistrature appelle en conséquence à la
mesure car l'institution judiciaire aux
services de l'état de droit et de chaque
citoyen sans distinction doit pouvoir
continuer de juger à l'abri des
pressions en toute indépendance et en
toute impartialité
est ce que le politique finalement ses
troupes ingéré dans les décisions de ces
deux affaires selon vous comme vous
semble comme le dit d'ailleurs un le le
conseil supérieur de la magistrature
écoutez quand on rend une décision de
justice on la rend je le rappelle au nom
du peuple français et le peuple français
quand ils voient les forces de l'ordre
qui sont menacés de mort il a il a un
sentiment de révolte
moi je critique très clairement je me
moque de ce que pense le conseil
supérieur de la magistrature
quand j'entends l'avocat général qui est
censé représenter le ministère public
c'est à dire le ministère de la justice
se tourner vers ceux qui ont commis à
cette tentative de crime et leur
expliquer que ce sont des chances pour
la france
les bras m'en tombent je pense que tous
les français sont révoltés
voilà et on a un moment l'impression
qu'il ya deux poids deux mesures on
poursuit sans cesse dès qu'il y à une un
problème de jospin enfin j'allais dire
de bavures judiciaires de terreur
j'étais rares perdants policière des
vars policière alors qu'elles sont
extrêmement minime mais on a
l'impression que les policiers à chaque
fois qu'ils sont menacés
la justice est particulièrement
clémentes il ya eu sept que ce soit dans
la décision sur vitry sur champigny et
bien on comprend que les policiers
soient révoltés et que les français ne
comprennent pas voilà les jugements de
la justice au nom du peuple français
il ya des moments où je me demande de
plus en plus si certains ne le rendent
pas au nom de leurs convictions
alors là les telle conviction vous dites
au nom de leurs convictions lesquels on
sait très bien qu'un certain nombre de
juges pour la victime et touffah le
coupable est toujours une victime
je répète quand je vois l'avocat général
qui explique ce tournant vers ceux qui
ont tenté d'assassiner des policiers
les brûlant que ce sont des chances pour
notre pour la france
franchement vous croyez que les
policiers pensent que c'est une chance
pour la france
vous croyez que des voyous qui ont
essayé d'assassiner des policiers c'est
une chance pour la france
moi je souhaiterais plutôt qu'il quitte
la france alors là la france a on va
parler d'ailleurs cette question des
migrations une nouvelle fois touché par
un attentat terroriste dans un
commissariat à rambouillet une femme
policier on les avait décédé le ministre
de l'intérieur à lui dévoilé les grandes
lignes du projet de la loi elle sera
présentée en conseil des ministres ce
sera mercredi
alors parmi ces mesures a suivi deux ans
après la sortie d'une personne
radicaliser l'amélioration du suivi
socio psychiatrique des personnes
potentiellement dangereuses mais
également à renforts sur le terrain
technologique regarde la loi doit nous
permettre d'être plus efficace en nous
renforçant sur le terrain de la
technologie qu'utilise les terroristes
le texte prévoit ainsi d'actualiser et
de pérenniser le recours aux algorithmes
c'est à dire le traitement automatisé
des données de connexion par la dgs si
nous n'oublions pas pour autant le suivi
humain puisque nous continuons à
recruter alors plus de surveillance des
données donc est ce que c'est le bon cap
ans en matière de lutte contre le
terrorisme
aujourd'hui ce terrain technologique
c'est un cap nécessaire mais c'est pas
le principal cap et c'est pas le cas
suffisant je suis originaire de provence
alpes côte d'azur
je vais vous prendre les trois attentats
de programme ski en provence alpes côte
d'azur
bon je vous le rappelle conduit à
l'assassinât de 91 personnes
l'attentât de nice le 14 juillet 86
morts par une personne qui était
condamné par la justice un étranger qui
aurait dû être expulsé
l'attentât de marseille la gare
saint-charles laura et maurane assassiné
par un clandestin
l'attentât qui a conduit aussi à la
salle si naples 3 personnes à la
cathédrale notre-dame de nice un
clandestin le lien entre immigration et
terrorisme même si je choque les bonnes
âmes est évident évident je vois même
maintenant enfin des responsables de de
certains partis qui leur paraissent
justement justement tiré mariani ce lien
entre ce rapprochement entre terrorisme
immigration est assez valérie pécresse
qu'il a fait c'était hier regarder il
faut cesser de nier le lien entre
terrorisme et l'immigration
tous les migrants qui arrivent sans
papiers aux frontières qui demandent
l'asile ne doivent pas pouvoir pénétrer
sur le sol européen
on doit pouvoir examiner leur demande
d'asile aux frontières et les renvoyer
chez eux s'ils ne sont pas persécutés
alors finalement examiné les demandes
d'asile aux frontières renvoyer les
personnes si elles ne sont pas
persécutés est ce que vous vous partagez
cette proposition de valérie pécresse et
côté valérie pécresse découvre la lune
c'est ce que dit le marine le pen depuis
des années voilà et puis valérie
pécresse les aider les élections
approchent donc on comprend que d'un
coup elle est rappelée par la réalité
voilà la réalité c'est quoi c'est
d'abord que chaque étrangers qui entrent
illégalement sur notre territoire ne
doit pas être régularisés autrement
c'est un appel d'air je rappelle que
l'assassin de de cette policière en fait
de cet agent administratif de la police
était quelqu'un qui restait dix ans sur
notre territoire et a été régularisée
est ce qu'un commerçant qui ne payent
pas par exemple le sens du recef pendant
dix ans lure fait de cadeau est ce que
quelqu'un comme vous et moi qui ne
payons pas nos impôts pendant dix ans
nous en fait cadeau
bah non il n'y a que pour les les
immigrés clandestins qu'on applique ce
genre de mesures donc il est évident que
toute personne condamnée sur notre
territoire de nationalité étranger doit
être immédiatement expulsée et il est
évident que tout étranger clandestins
qui est sur notre territoire ne doit pas
être régularisés avant d'être sortis de
nos frontières
alors concernant les flux migratoires
encore un drame c'est au large de la
libye en méditerranée 130 personnes
migrantes sont mortes dans un naufrage
l'om j'ai sos méditerranée pointe la
responsabilité des états européens en
regarder les étapes dick leur
responsabilité de coordonner les
opérations de recherche et de sauvetage
laissant les acteurs privés et la
société civile combler le vide mortel
qu'ils laissent derrière eux
nous pouvons voir le résultat de 7
action délibérée dans la mer autour de
notre navire alors comment fait
aujourd'hui pour vous pour empêcher ces
drames humains en méditerranée pour
empêcher que les morts en méditerranée
la solution j'allais dire est peut-être
plus simple que ce que certains le
disent il faut avoir un message clair
qui ait aucune immigration régulière ne
sera tolérée c'est ce qu'ont fait les
australiens je vous rappelle que j'ai
été à un moment responsable des français
de l'étranger
j'ai regardé ce qui se fait en australie
l'australie avait le même problème un
moment le gouvernement a dit tout ce qui
arrive par un bateau ne mettront pas le
pied sur le territoire australien et ils
ont été sauvés mais mis à l'écart sur
des îles où ils n'ont aucun accès au
territoire australien est leur seule
solution est de retourner dans leur pays
d'origine
pourquoi en réalité je condamne des
opérations comme sos méditerranée c'est
à dire que consciemment ou
inconsciemment ils se rendent complices
des passeurs consciemment ou
inconsciemment ils sont complices de ces
gens qui malheureusement perdre la vie
en méditerranée si le message de l'union
européenne est claire vous ne serez
jamais autorisé à mettre un pied sur
l'europe
si nous passons par exemple comme l'a
fait l'australie désaccord avec d'autres
pays en disant bien tous ceux qui sont
sur des bateaux quand ils sont secourus
et quand ils sont en danger il faut
laisser courir sont ramenées sur un
point qui n'est pas l'europe
alors vous verrez que ces bateaux
s'arrêteront parce que pourquoi tous ces
bateaux continue parce qu'il ya l'espoir
et même plus que l'espoir l'assurance
pour tous ces gens d'être un jour
régulariser et enlever cet espoir c'est
le meilleur moyen d'arrêter cette cet
afflux de bateaux et d'arrêter aussi ses
morts en mer alors tiré mariani l'ouest
vraiment que quelques secondes peut être
un mot sur votre avenir vous êtes
candidat à la présidence de la région
paca vous présenter face à renaud
muselier
vous avez tous les deux étaient dans la
même famille politique il y a quelques
années en quelques mots qu'est ce qui
vous distingue de lui aujourd'hui est ce
qui nous distingue c'est qu'on n'a pas
le même parcours aujourd'hui on a eu les
mêmes les mêmes opinions il ya quelques
années mais aujourd'hui il est renaud
muselier évolué très clairement vers
monsieur macro je vous rappelle que son
adjoint entre guillemets monsieur
christian estrosi demande clairement une
alliance avec macron regarder la presse
encore d'aujourd'hui qui dira nous
e lle hésitent à faire l'alliance avec
les habits de monsieur macron moi ma
position est claire je veux dire je suis
clairement dans l'opposition je veux une
autre région
je veux une région où les choses
changent mais je veux en tout cas
clairement m'inscrire dans une
opposition à ce gouvernement qui dans
notre région comme dans toute la france
nous conduit à la catastrophe
merci beaucoup tiré mariani d'avoir
répondu à nos questions sur rt france ce
matin je le rappelle vous êtes député
européen du rassemblement national
on le disait candidat aux régionales
pour la présidence de la région paca